este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfear vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la crisis de el coronavirus ha puesto un
debate sobre la mesa las bake hasta qué
punto la libertad de expresión ampara a
la gente que publica noticias que sabe
que son mentiras estos meses hemos visto
a toda clase de páginas web incluso
canales de youtube decir toda clase de
salvajada sobre el coronavirus
[Música]
y no sólo hablamos de teorías de la
conspiración por ejemplo en muchas
páginas web se han llegado a recomendar
barbaridades como beber lejía para curar
el cob y 19 paréntesis esto es falso la
lejía no cura el coronavirus y además es
venenosa si alguno se ha planteado
seguir alguno de estos consejos no lo
hagáis fin del paréntesis pero lo cierto
es que tantísimas pitiús han llevado a
muchos gobiernos a plantearse la
posibilidad de crear leyes para evitar
que cualquiera publique cualquier
burrada y no sólo hablamos de gobiernos
plataformas como esta misma como youtube
y otras parecidas como facebook han
sacado medidas como estas
[Música]
se ocupa facebook de las noticias falsas
a través de verificadores de datos de
terceros
exacto todos intentan solucionar el
problema de las picnics incluso muchos
youtubers están viviendo activamente que
el propio youtube actúe de forma
contundente contra muchos de estos
canales que promueven bulos y entonces
en ese momento es cuando aparece esta
historia y nos hace a todos
replantearnos todo lo que pensábamos
sobre la verdad
así es como wake art pasó de ser la joya
de los analistas a convertirse en un
escándalo contable de 2.200 millones de
dólares ella sé lo que estaréis pensando
pero qué tiene que ver un escándalo
financiero con las pequeños pues creedme
mucho hablamos de uno de los mayores
escándalos financieros de la historia de
alemania un escándalo que incluye
fraudes por más de 1.900 millones de
euros y las autoridades alemanas no sólo
no fueron capaces de verlo sino que
además tacharon de conspira laico y de
phoenix a todos aquellos que saltaron la
primera voz de alarma y ya sé lo que me
vais a decir muchos wild-card de verdad
fue un escándalo tan grande es la
primera vez que oigo hablar de esta
empresa pues sí lo cierto es que wire
card no es la marca más conocida del
planeta tierra pero seguro que todos
habréis utilizado alguno de esos
servicios en algún momento de vuestra
vida
[Música]
se trata de una de las mayores empresas
de pagos del mundo que habéis comprado
algo por internet es muy probable que
sin saberlo hayáis utilizado la
tecnología de wild-card especialmente si
habéis pagado por algo relacionado con
casinos o con el no por porque si esta
startup alemana se había especializado
en este nicho de mercado concreto el del
no por y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos pagos por internet pues seguro
que esta empresa estará arrasando ahora
mismo si hay un sector que ha salido
beneficiado con la crisis del
coronavirus ese es el online en un
momento donde todos hemos comprado cosas
por internet las empresas de pagos
online han crecido una barbaridad así
que wire card tendría que estar
arrasando en estos momentos verdad pues
nada más lejos de la realidad
atentos
white hart colarse y se declara
insolvente 25 de junio de 2020 habéis
oído bien si por ado se ha hecho famosa
wire card en los últimos meses es por
haber protagonizado el mayor escándalo
financiero del año según parece se ha
inventado la mitad de su negocio
hablamos de una empresa que ha llegado a
valer 24 mil millones de euros y que
acaba de irse a pique por fraude por
hacer una comparación en el escándalo
financiero de stratton ok mont el de la
película del lobo de wallstreet de
martin scorsese hablábamos sólo de 200
millones de dólares es decir que si esta
película dio para que scorsese hiciera
una película con este otro escándalo
podríamos hablar de cinco temporadas de
la hb o por lo menos porque para asombro
de todos todo esto ocurría mientras las
autoridades alemanas no sólo hacían la
vista gorda sino que incluso denunciaban
a los periodistas que lo investigaban y
de que les acusaban exacto decir news y
manipulación de mercados puede que
sorprenda pero a diferencia de la prensa
generalista la prensa económica suele
estar mucho más regulada pensando bien
si un analista financiero público
información falsa sobre una empresa
puede hundir o subir su valoración en
bolsa y por eso hay leyes que intentan
evitar esto
[Música]
el problema pues que a veces estas leyes
pueden terminar persiguiendo a las
personas equivocadas así que este vídeo
puede servir como una fábula sobre las
ficciones las finanzas y el precio de la
verdad porque la pregunta que hoy nos
hacemos es en qué consiste exactamente
el escándalo de wire card en que han
fallado exactamente las autoridades
públicas que no lo vieron venido como
podemos intentar evitar que vuelvan a
ocurrir cosas así hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas pero antes tenemos que
hablar de otro tipo de delitos aparte de
los financieros si hablamos de internet
pensadlo bien durante todos estos días
de cuarentena confinamiento y
coronavirus estamos utilizando internet
más que nunca y eso significa que
estamos viviendo algo así como la
versión online de chicago años 30
[Música]
no lo digo yo lo dicen todos los
estudios de ciberseguridad estafas
filtraciones de datos y robo de
privacidad nunca ha sido más peligroso
navegar por internet que ahora pero
tranquilos existe una vacuna contra los
hackers y eso es conectarse internet a
través de una vpn como subsal
[Música]
se usar que es una vpn fantástica por
muchas razones seguro que todos sabéis
que ha ido alguna vez en una de estas
webs de spam que intentan estafar osos
con papas popups por todas partes a este
tipo de prácticas se les llama fishing
pues bien su shark tiene una herramienta
que se llama king web que bloquea todos
estos pop-up si todos esos enlaces que
pueden ser un auténtico peligro pero no
sólo eso con una única cuenta de surf
shark podría registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tablet el portátil no hay ningún límite
de dispositivos
y como siempre tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual poli y básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado en acá
tendréis un 85% de descuento más tres
meses extra totalmente gratuitos es más
podéis probar su usar durante los
primeros 30 días sin ningún tipo de
compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y dicho todo esto
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
gran esperanza europea imagina que
tienes un ecommerce y vendes vamos a
decir camisas hawaianas por internet yo
te compro una camisa por diez euros eso
significa que al terminar la transacción
en mi cuenta de banco tiene que ver diez
euros menos y en la tuya tiene que haber
diez euros más hasta aquí todo es lógico
la pregunta es quién verifica que tanto
tu banco como el mío hayan registrado
esta compraventa lo más probable es que
tu banco sea distinto del mío sobre todo
si estamos en distintos países pues bien
ese es el trabajo de las empresas de
pagos electrónicos
[Música]
seguro que te vienen a la cabeza
muchísimas empresas de este sector
mastercard visa pues bien wire card es
una plataforma que permitía o permite
que tu ecommerce pueda aceptar casi
todos los distintos métodos de pago del
mundo en otras palabras si yo te quiero
pagar con visa mastercard o cualquier
otro sistema wire card lo hace posible
sin hacer cola los consumidores pueden
poner varios productos de distintas
tiendas en su carrito de la compra y
pagar con el smartphone en una sola
transacción estás listo para el futuro
de los pagos esta empresa nació en el
año 1999 y como tantas otras empresas de
internet que nacieron por esa época wire
card estuvo a punto de desaparecer
cuando estalló la burbuja de las
puntocom si la crisis de el coronavirus
ha sido el boom de las empresas de
internet la crisis del año 2000 fue todo
lo contrario y fue en este momento
cuando wire card valía menos que un
rollo de papel higiénico en este momento
es cuando apareció el antihéroe de
nuestra historia el señor markus braun
aparte de parecer el malo de robocop
markus braun tenía una idea genial para
hacer crecer a esta empresa como la
espuma no por y casinos
seguramente no lo sepáis pero estas
empresas suelen estar totalmente
aisladas del resto del mercado por
ejemplo la mayor parte de las empresas
de métodos de pago rechazan trabajar con
las empresas de no por es decir
entretenimiento para adultos sin embargo
esas páginas también necesitan procesar
pagos muchos pagos
así que wire card se convirtió enseguida
en la única o una de las pocas empresas
de pagos que no discriminaba al
entretenimiento para adultos conclusión
brawn compró un negocio ruinoso y cinco
años más tarde estaba entrando en la
bolsa alemana tal cual como lo oís y
para qué querrían entrar en bolsa os
preguntaréis pues muy sencillo
necesitaban financiación rápida para
poder dar el siguiente paso la expansión
internacional
y ahora quiero que os quedéis con este
dato por esa época la acción de
wild-card estaba en los dedos recordar
este número porque es muy importante
cinco euros por acción en 2005 con toda
esta liquidez que aportaron todos los
inversores 'wild card' dio el gran salto
así que en el año 2007 abrieron su
oficina en singapur y contrataron al
segundo antihéroe de esta historia el
señor ed horneaban director de wildcard
en asia y pacifico
[Música]
exacto también es otro señor que parece
el malo de una película de serie b y
cuál fue la estrategia de este hombre
para conquistar asia es muy fácil
comprar todo lo que se movía
de repente wire card se dedicó a comprar
toda clase de pequeñas empresas que
ofrecían pagos online en mercados
locales una empresita en filipinas una
empresita en dubai una empresa está por
aquí una empresita por allá y así hasta
que en el año 2014 wild card ya ofrecía
servicio en australia nueva zelanda
sudáfrica y turquía para estos momentos
la acción atentos ya estaba en 30
empresas
es decir que en menos de 10 años había
multiplicado su valor por 6 las
reuniones de accionistas parecían
fiestas de cumpleaños y por lo que se
estaba viendo en las noticias que siguen
apareciendo algunas de estas fiestas
parecían más bien una escena del lomo de
wallstreet cada año era mejor que el
anterior pero no os equivoquéis ya en
aquel momento había cosas que no
terminaban de cuadrar en esta empresa
por esos momentos el financial times ya
empezaba a sospechar
o en cartes una empresa alemana casi
desconocida que vale cinco mil millones
de euros pero también es un puzle crece
a un ritmo apabullante pero compra
compañías de pagos muy oscuras en todo
el mundo para mantener ese crecimiento
este artículo es del año 2015 y
básicamente se planteaba una gran
pregunta cómo es posible que comprar a
empresas ruinosas en asia y que en tan
solo un año las hicieran rentables de la
noche a la mañana nadie era capaz de
explicarlo a ciencia cierta y esto
podría haber servido para que las
autoridades financieras de alemania se
pusieran a analizar esta compañía en
este país la autoridad que se encarga de
estas cosas se llama el vacío sin
embargo no parece que estuviera muy por
la labor de meterse a hacer inspecciones
para que se trataba del gran milagro
alemán tal vez ese facebook europeo con
el que cualquier país soñaría para que
os hagáis una idea en 2016 ya estaban
comprando la división de pagos online de
citigroup
en otras palabras entraban en el mercado
estadounidense y por la puerta grande
algo parecido hicieron en brasil otro
pedazo mercado de más de 200 millones de
consumidores
la acción atentos llevaría más de
cuarenta y seis euros y en ese momento
año 2017 una revista alemana publica
este artículo
pune de 250 millones de euros que tras
del milagro bursátil de white hart
básicamente wire card decía que compraba
empresas de pagos en asia que eran
prácticamente desconocidas y que valían
muy poco ellos se quedaban con su
cartera de clientes reestructuraban la
empresa y en un año ya daban beneficios
para que os hagáis una idea en sólo
cinco años wire card ya estaba
triplicando sus beneficios es más en
enero de 2019 'wild card' ya valía más
que el mismísimo deutsche bahn es decir
su valor en bolsa estaba por encima del
banco más grande de alemania en este
momento es cuando entraron por la puerta
grande en el dax-30 que es el índice con
las empresas más grandes de la bolsa
alemana
y de repente se coronaron pasaron de ser
una empresa de métodos de pago que
trabajaba con páginas no por ser la
plataforma que utilizaban más de 100
aerolíneas y cadenas de supermercados
como alt y para entonces la acción ya
estaba por ciento 90 euros
[Música]
desde luego que esto no es nada
comparado con las historias de éxito de
amazon o facebook pero no estaba nada
mal especialmente para ser una empresa
europea en sólo 15 años habían pasado de
valer cinco euros a valer 190 euros por
acción no está nada mal verdad bueno
pues de repente cuando todo el mundo
estaba encantado con wild card acción
empezó a aclarar empezó a caer por
primera vez y diréis pero por qué pues
atentos los logos solitarios de la bolsa
y si te dijera que se puede ganar dinero
cuando una acción cae en bolsa es decir
que técnicamente puedes comprar acciones
de empresas que crees que van a ir a
peor y aún así ganar dinero a esta
técnica se le llama comprar a corto en
inglés lo llaman short serie os cuento
cómo funciona
imagina que tú tienes una acción de
wild-card en diciembre de 2018 su precio
de mercado en ese momento es de más o
menos 190 euros y en ese momento yo te
digo oye mira préstame tu acción y yo te
la devuelvo dentro de un año con un
interés tú me dices vale genial mira no
tenía pensado venderla así que toda tuya
mira eso que me llevo un pequeño interés
dentro de
[Música]
según me des la acción yo la vengo y me
quedo con esos 190 euros en el bolsillo
yo espero que dentro de un año guard
card se la va a pegar en la bolsa si mis
cálculos son correctos en diciembre de
2019 la acción de wire card va a estar
vamos a decir en diez euros es decir que
en ese momento vuelvo a comprar la
acción por diez euros y te la devuelvo
con el interés y voilà acabo de ganar
180 euros bueno algo menos por la tasa
de interés con una empresa que se acaba
de arruinar como os podéis imaginar esto
es una práctica muy arriesgada y
normalmente la gente que compra cortos
suele ser un tipo muy especial de
inversor es lo que se llaman los
contraria es decir la gente que lleva la
contra al mercado pensadlo bien en enero
de 2019 wire card iba viento en popa el
bafin alemán aseguraba que la empresa
tenía todas sus cuentas en orden igual
que es la empresa que habitaba las
cuentas daba fe de que el negocio de
wire karts no tenía ningún problema en
otras palabras que todas las fuentes de
autoridad posibles decían que wild card
es el futuro había que estar loco
a comprar a corto una empresa así verdad
pues así es como son los short sellers
una especie de tribu única dentro del
mundo de las finanzas
algo así como un conspiranoico pero con
una diferencia en este caso tu verdad
tiene un precio estás arriesgando tu
dinero porque realmente crees que algo
no va tan bien como todo es crítico pero
no sólo eso veréis normalmente los
inversores a cortos suelen tener muy
mala fama a fin de cuentas son como
buitres se benefician cuando todo va mal
y todo eso explica que febrero del año
2019 encontráramos una noticia como ésta
a fin prohíbe las compras a corto de
acciones de wildcard después de un
varapalo en bolsa
exacto las autoridades financieras
alemanas es decir el bafin querían
proteger a su pequeño facebook no
querían que un montón de inversores a
corto un dieran la empresa a propósito a
fin de cuentas si los demás inversores
ven como hay mucha gente comprando a
corto es muy probable que dejen de
invertir en esta empresa y que la acción
baje y como os podéis imaginar nadie en
alemania quería que wild card bajara en
bolsa
así que en ese momento esos lobos
solitarios que apostaban en contra de
wild-card eran vistos como el clásico
conspiranoico con el gorrito de papel de
aluminio y por supuesto muchos pensaban
que el financial times estaba publicando
una serie de phoenix es decir de bulos
porque estaban secretamente compinchados
con los inversores a corto así que como
decíamos al principio las facebook en el
mundo de las finanzas se castigan a fin
el observatorio financiero alemán ha
presentado una denuncia criminal contra
dos periodistas del financial times y
varios compradores a corto acusándoles
de manipulación potencial del mercado
por reportar supuestas irregularidades
en las cuentas de wild-card y ya sé lo
que estáis pensando
menuda inteligencia el estado alemán
estuvo luchando contra los únicos que
decían la verdad y si tenéis razón es
cierto ahora que ya conocemos el final
de esta historia es muy fácil decir que
es una injusticia pero que habréis
pensado si hubierais leído esta noticia
en 2019 que habrías pensado si os
hubieran dicho que un periódico está
publicando pequeños
y que les van a llevar a los juzgados
por manipulación de los mercados
habríais dicho que es una injusticia o
tal vez os parecería fantástico que se
filtren las peñas de una vez por todas
os lo dejo para que lo penséis en
cualquier caso ni siquiera los esfuerzos
del bafin sirvieron para evitar la caída
de wild-card atentos
[Música]
el escándalo que sacudió a alemania
octubre de 2019
la acción de wire card estalla por los
110 euros por mucho que el bafin haya
prohibido las compras a corto el panel
del times sigue publicando análisis que
no deja muy bien a esta empresa todavía
siguen sin entender cómo es posible
comprar empresas pequeñitas en asia y
que de golpe y porrazo de tantísimos
beneficios en tan poco tiempo y en este
momento cuando el mercado le estaba
empezando a dar la espalda wire card la
empresa se reunió y tomó esta decisión
well card contrata kpmg para hacer una
auditoría independiente tras las
acusaciones del financial times los
muchos no habréis entendido la noticia
no os preocupéis os voy a explicar el
swahili financiero las grandes empresas
están obligadas a dejar que otra empresa
la revise las cuentas estas empresas que
revisan la contabilidad de otras
empresas se las llama auditoras en el
mundo existen cuatro grandes auditoras
que seguramente os sonarán bajo el
nombre de las big four son deloitte
pricewaterhousecoopers y white que es la
que antes se llamaba arms and young y
kpmg
hasta este momento igual era la empresa
que auditaba las cuentas de wild-card
pero como el lado no se fiaba dijeron
vale pues nos vamos a que los auditen
otra empresa para que os quedéis más
tranquilos y probablemente el hecho de
que contrataran a kpmg también tenía
truco a fin de cuentas es markus braun
el ceo de la empresa ese que se parecía
al malo de robocop había trabajado
previamente en kpmg probablemente
pensara que sus amigos de kpmg serían
más comprensivos con él que cualquier
otra auditora sin embargo esta jugada no
le pudo haber salido peor atentos
wild-card vuelve a explotar tras una
auditoría especial de kpmg básicamente
tanto igual como kpmg descubrieron que
wire card se había inventado mil 900
millones de euros de beneficios tal cual
según wire card estaban arrasando en
filipinas es más según ellos casi todos
los filipinos usaban sus sistemas tanto
éxito habían tenido en este país que
estaban dando unos ingresos de 1900
millones de euros hasta el momento todo
el mundo se creía estas cifras a fin de
cuentas porque iban a mentir quién se va
a ir a filipinas para comprobar si el
negocio existe o no pues bien en este
momento alguien decidió acercarse
físicamente a las supuestas oficinas de
wire card en manila con semejante
volumen de negocio lo que uno se
imaginaría sería un edificio enorme
verdad pues nada de eso el imperio de
wire card filipinas se limitaba a una
oficinita compartida con una empresa de
autobuses pero no sólo eso el propio
banco central de filipinas aseguraba que
a duras penas conocía la existencia de
una empresa llamada wire card
pensadlo bien con semejante volumen de
negocio wire card tendría que haber
estado investigada por el banco central
es más según la ley filipina si el
volumen de una empresa sobrepasa el 5
por ciento de las reservas de divisa
extranjera que tiene todo el país están
obligados a pasar una inspección no es
que hayan hecho nada malo simplemente
sería una inspección rutinaria 2.000
millones de euros habrían sido más que
suficientes para que las autoridades les
hubieran hecho una inspección rutinaria
sin embargo war card filipinas era un
negocio más falso que el alma de judas
un negocio de cartón-piedra como os
podéis imaginar tan pronto como se
descubrió esta noticia
los directivos de wild-card empezaron a
caer como moscas
[Música]
la policía hace una redada en las
oficinas de white hart en singapur tras
un informe que acusa de fraude al
gigante de los pagos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
este o de wild-card markus braun
arrestado después de que el escándalo de
los dos mil millones de dólares se
explote mientras tanto en el momento en
el que hacemos este vídeo wire card ya
se ha declarado en bancarrota y algunos
de sus directivos están en paradero
desconocido el abogado de la empresa
niega haber tenido ningún contacto con
su cliente básicamente no saben lo que
es wire card el contable está
desaparecido en filipinas y el mundo
entero empieza a desconfiar de alemania
si las autoridades financieras de este
país cubrieron este escándalo que otras
empresas no habrán hecho algo parecido
por el momento ya están empezando a
salir los nombres de los funcionarios
del patín que estarían directamente
envueltos en este escándalo pensadlo
bien en este caso no es simplemente que
las autoridades no fueron capaces de
detectar un fraude es que trabajaron
activamente para silenciar a todos
aquellos que levantaron la voz de alarma
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros cómo se podría haber evitado
este escándalo quién controla a los
reguladores hasta qué punto esta
historia nos puede hacer ver el debate
de las pequeños desde otro punto de
vista personalmente yo no tengo muy
claro lo que pienso sobre las técnicas
pero esta historia me está obligando a
replantearme muchas cosas de nuevo no
tengo una opinión muy clara pero me
encantaría leer la vuestra podéis
dejarme la en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribirse a visual política y donde la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]
h